my favorite Oscar moment is it  immediately followed my least favorite  Oscar moment ever my least favorite  Oscar moment of course was when they  opened the envelope the night that the  war room was nominated and they didn't  say the war room that was my very least  favorite Oscar moment but my most  favorite Oscar moment came immediately  thereafter I don't know what it is  you're at the Oscars and you somehow  nobody tells you about this but  apparently instinctually you know that  if you lose what you do is you rise you  walk out of the room you walk down the  stairs and you go to the loser bar I  mean it was like everybody who had lost  in their category that night was down  there drowning their sorrows and it was  awesome it was great I was like yeah you  know it's not so bad